[Applaus]
[Musik]
für viele menschen außerhalb
deutschlands wird das einstige land der
dichter und denker welches die ganze
welt wechselweise mal unterjochen und
mal retten will heute wie ein
monolithischer block ein geeignetes land
der glückseligen ein zusammenhängendes
gebiet in dem die wirtschaft floriert
oder wohlstand praktisch jeden winkel
erreicht eine echte supermacht das
kraftwerk europas ein land dessen
probleme klein erscheinen im vergleich
zu denen die wir in anderen teilen des
alten kontinents finden können nun
soweit der naive mythos wie so oft ist
die wahrheit eine ganz andere
tatsächlich ist deutschland ein land der
tausend teilungen und spaltungen
historisch kulturell sozial
wirtschaftlich ideologisch und
gesellschaftlich in jeder epoche welche
dieses land durchlebt hat sind dabei
neue gegensätze und polarisierungen
hinzugekommen sie starten und überlagern
sich immer mehr und führen zu einer
immer komplexeren immer stärker
zerklüfteten gesellschaft ja gar zu
parallelgesellschaften die außer ihrer
des geografischen aufenthaltsortes nicht
mehr viel miteinander gemein haben die
spaltung in deutschland sind der stoff
für eine ganze serie von videos vergiss
daher bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren falls sich dieses thema auch
so interessiert wie uns und aktiviere
bitte auch die kleine glocke damit du
keines unserer videos in zukunft
verpasst gut in diesem video wollte also
mit jener deutschen klub beginnen die
geschichtlich wo die augenfälligste ist
denn obwohl die teilung deutschlands in
einem kapitalistischen westen und einem
kommunistischen osten nach dem fall der
mauer am 3 oktober 1990 war endete ist
sie auch heute nach über 30 jahren noch
immer wahrnehmbar man könnte sagen dass
es eine unsichtbare mauer gibt welche
diese zwei ganz unterschiedlichen
deutschlands trend aber lasst uns das
wohl mal kurz die geschichte
rekapitulieren
nachdem deutschland seit 1945 politisch
geteilt war schluss die kommunistische
regierung ostdeutschlands 1952 die
grenzen zum westen die einzige ausnahme
wo noch ein minimum an bewegungsfreiheit
zwischen ost und west lieb war berlin
doch einige jahre später 1961 errichtete
die ddr angesichts der hohen zahl von
flüchtlingen die aus dem osten in den
westen flüchteten die berüchtigte
berliner mauer seitdem wurde die
historische hauptstadt des deutschen
reiches zur lebendige präsentation an
der teilung welche die politik der
ganzen welt für jahrzehnte prägte ost
gegen west kapitalismus gegen
kommunismus die nato gegen den
warschauer pakt und nicht nur das diese
physische grenze er stellte sich dann
über ganz deutschland in einigen
abschnitten in form einer mauer in
anderen in form von stark befestigten
mehrfach zäunen mit stacheldraht land
nehmen selbstschussanlagen und
wachtürmen voller drachen hat keine
soldaten das alles war kein platz denn
die an der grenze eingesetzten grenze
hatten einen klaren und strecken
bisschen jeden zu erschießen der zu
fliehen versuchte entgegen
internationalem recht wurden fast
eineinhalb millionen anti personen minen
entlang der grenze verlegt wir sprechen
hier von einer spaltung einer isolation
wie dazu bei trug eine wirtschaftliche
politische und vor allem soziale wunde
zu schaffen eine wunde welche die
zukunft des deutschen volkes bis heute
prägen sollte
44.000 soldaten der deutschen
demokratischen republik hatten 40 jahre
lang in auftrag das deutsche volk mit
waffengewalt auseinanderzuhalten ihre
mission war es jeden kontakt zwischen
beiden teilen des volkes zu verhindern
[Musik]
und offensichtlich waren auch jenseits
der ideologische frage die wege beider
länder in jeder hinsicht sehr
unterschiedlich im laufe der zeit
versorgte die existenz dieser beiden
deutschlands wichtige unterschiede nicht
nur in bezug auf das wirtschaftliche
entwicklung sondern auch in sozialer
hinsicht in diesem video werden wir
daher versuchen jede unterschiede die
auch heute 30 jahre nach der
wiedervereinigung noch sichtbar und
spürbar sind und ihre auswirkungen auf
die politische wirtschaftliche und
soziale realität des heutigen
deutschlands aus einem anderen
unkonventionellen blickwinkel zu
untersuchen
[Musik]
eine unvollendete wiedervereinigung
es ist kein großes geheimnis sowie das
zerstören viel einfacher ist als das
erschaffen so ist auch das teilen viel
einfacher als das zusammenführen
jenseits der wirtschaft liegt dabei die
vielleicht schwierigste aufgabe darin
gesellschaftliche unterschiede
auszugleichen und zu integrieren
[Musik]
denn sozialer und politischer hinsicht
gibt es bedeutende unterschiede zwischen
den beiden ehemaligen deutschen republik
bis hin zu einer menge misstrauen und
argwohn zwischen ost und westdeutschen
zum beispiel fühlen sich viele deutsche
aus der ehemaligen ddr in staatlichen
institutionen und politischen und
juristischen positionen
unterrepräsentiert was ein gewisses
gefühl der ungleichheit führt um ein
beispiel zu nennen acht von zehn
richtern und staatsanwälten in boston
sind im westen aufgewachsen und kein
großes börsennotiertes unternehmen des
landes hat seinen sitz im osten
außerhalb berlins darüber hinaus gibt es
sogar klare politische grenzen im osten
erzielt sowohl die nachfolgepartei der
totalitären kommunistischen ddr
regierungspartei sed die sich
mittlerweile in die linke umbenannt hat
wesentlich bessere wahlergebnisse als im
westteil deutschlands ebenso wie die
neue rechte partei alternative für
deutschland mit der keine der anderen
etablierten parteien zusammenarbeiten
will
[Musik]
und nicht nur das wenn wir uns kritisch
stadt berlin anschauen kannst du sehen
dass die bezirke in denen diese beiden
parteien die größte unterstützung ernten
genau dort liegen wo als das
kommunistische ostberlin war und die
offensichtliche frage lautet was erklärt
eine solche spaltung was steckt hinter
diesen unterschieden die sogar die wahl
fair essen so weit auseinanderklaffen
lassen die wahrheit ist dass die
deutschen im allgemeinen immer noch
unterschiedliche arten haben die
gesellschaft zu sehen und konkrete
aspekte der politik zu verstehen der
klassiker ist die frage der
einwanderungspolitik der erfolg der
alternative für deutschland im osten hat
natürlich viel mit der ablehnung von
angela merkels flüchtlingspolitik zu tun
die dazu geführt hat dass das land sei
2015 seine türen für millionen von
menschen aus der dritten welt geöffnet
hat
[Musik]
und das macht durchaus sinn schließlich
war aus deutschland traditionell nie ein
ort ungeregelter zuwanderung so dass
viele ostdeutsche diesen zustrom mit
argwohn und misstrauen betrachten denn
selbst jemand der sonst rein gar nichts
gegen ausländer hat kann gegen diese art
von einwanderungspolitik sein wenn er
über eine ganz andere lebenserfahrung
verfügt trotz alldem obwohl die große
mehrheit der deutschen der meinung ist
dass sich ihr leben seit der
wiedervereinigung verbessert hat sind
ist gerade die ostdeutschen die der
meinung sind dass sie am meisten davon
profitiert haben
[Musik]
tatsächlich hat sich der anteil der
ostdeutschen die ihre lebensqualität mit
715 und höher bewerten zwischen 1991 und
2009 10 zu 8 4 fast und liegt nun bei 59
prozent der gesamtgruppe
aber lasst uns einen augenblick
innehalten nur weil sich die dinge
verbessert haben heißt das nicht dass
die unterschiede verschwunden sind der
zusammenhalt kommt nicht so schnell wie
gedacht und nun ist klar dass der
zeitraum von 20 jahren der ursprünglich
für die bewältigung der teilung
deutschlands veranschlagt wurde ist viel
zu kurz bemessen braucht aber erst nach
dem anderen lasst uns zunächst die
wirtschaftlichen unterschiede unter die
lupe nehmen denn beim geld hört die
freundschaft ja bekanntlich aus
ein land zwei geschwindigkeiten
politik und wahlpräferenzen sind nicht
der einzige bereich in den abgrund die
für unterschiede zwischen den beiden
deutschlands finden können auch in der
wirtschaft zeigt sich ein ähnliches
phänomen offensichtlich ist es nicht
immer einfach von heute auf morgen von
einer sozialistischen planwirtschaft in
der alles vom staat gelenkt wird so
einer kapitalistischen zu wechseln oder
besser gesagt es ist nicht immer so
einfach diese lücke zu schließen und
erst recht wenn alle der beiden seiten
drei oder viermal erna ist als die
andere nach der wiedervereinigung
arbeiteten weniger als zehn prozent der
betriebe mit gewinnen die meisten der
neuen unternehmen entsprachen nicht den
standards des westlichen marktes die
aussies verfügten 1991 über ein drei mal
niedrigeres pro kopf bip als die wessis
und ihr bruttoeinkommen lag 50 prozent
unter dem ihrer westlichen landsleute
und obwohl sich diese unterschiede seite
erheblich verringert haben ist 30 jahre
später immer noch keine vollständige
angleichung erreicht worden
[Applaus]
das bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf ist in
austin heute immer noch 30 prozent
niedriger als im westen die jährlichen
haushaltseinkommen sind was 20 prozent
niedriger ein unterschied der noch
größer ist wenn wir den öffentlichen
sektor ausklammern hinzu kommt dass die
arbeitslosigkeit höher liegt darüber
hinaus verfügt ein erwachsener im westen
über ein durchschnittliches
nettovermögen von 120.000 euro was man
als doppelt so hoch ist wie der
durchschnitt von 50.000 euro im osten
deutschlands außerdem ist die umkehrung
der bevölkerungspyramide viel
ausgeprägter weil viele jungen menschen
in den westen gezogen sind der
investitions und kapitalfluss in die
ehemalige deutsche demokratische
republik war immens aber die menschen
sind in die andere richtung gegangen die
kinder die dort hätten geboren werden
sollen sind einfach nicht da aber es
geht dem osten auch einige dinge die
tatsächlich besser sind als im westen
zum beispiel die infrastruktur das
stimmt das war kein versprecher von mir
die von helmut kohl versprochenen
blühenden landschaften sind was diesen
punkt angeht wirklichkeit geworden als
die waage staaten wieder vereinigt
wurden fehlte es in der ddr an modernen
autobahn die eisenbahnen waren total
veraltet und im grunde waren alles
verkehrsnetze völlig marode
[Musik]
deswegen wurde ein milliardenschweres
investitionsprogramm im osten realisiert
bezahlt aus den steuern der deutschen
aber auch mit europäischen mitteln das
ergebnis weil die sanierung bzw der bau
tausender kilometer neuer bundesstraßen
und autobahnen und ein komplett
erneuertes schienennetz enders rund 30
milliarden euro investiert wurden die
politiker ließen sich wirklich nicht
lumpen und pumpen das geld ihrer
steuerzahler in die neuen bundesländer
natürlich war ein solcher akt der
großzügigkeit nicht unumstritten denn
während ihre steuergelder in austin mit
vollen händen ausgegeben wurden willi
qualität der infrastruktur in
westdeutschland dem epizentrum der
anatomischen wettbewerbsfähigkeit immer
weiter zurück wenn du mal durch
ostdeutschland reist wirst du selbst
sehen das viele bahnsystem moderner sind
als die im westen und sich auch viele
straßen in einen besseren zustand
befinden und auf besser und modernerer
verkehrswegeplanung beruhen das sorgt
für neid und unmut bei einigen
westdeutschen dies nicht ein großteil
der ausgaben finanziert haben aber warum
wurde überhaupt so massiv in die
infrastruktur investiert
[Musik]
der grundgedanke waren neben der
vereinigung des territoriums die
produktivität der industrie um was zu
erhöhen und so die unterschiede zwischen
den beiden seiten in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht bei produktion und löhnen zu
verringern etwas das mehr oder weniger
erreicht worden ist wenn auch noch immer
mit einigen gefälle dieses gibt es aber
auch zwischen regionen im westen kurse
bieten die menschen ja auch ärmer als in
oberbayern in den neuen bundesländern
bestand das hauptproblem kurz vor der
wiedervereinigung darin was mit den
riesigen praktisch funktionsunfähige und
sehr unproduktive staatsbetrieben der
ddr geschehen sollte hier gab es nur die
möglichkeit einen alles andere als
einfachen privatisierungsprozess
einzuleiten der noch von der regierung
der ddr über die sogenannte
treuhandanstalt eingeleitet worden war
[Musik]
liegt treuhandanstalt war eine
einrichtung die 1990 vom ddr ministerrat
geschaffen wurde und bis 1994 tätig war
ihr ziel und ihre aufgabe waren es die
mehr als 8000 sogenannten volkseigenen
betriebe des sozialistischen
deutschlands die damals fast vier
millionen menschen beschäftigten zu
privatisieren oder zu liquidieren
die herausforderung bestand nun darin
all diese unternehmen und ihre
vermögenswerte in so kurzer zeit auf dem
markt zu platzieren warum weil diese
massiven und ineffizienten
organisationen hauptsächlich auf den
handel mit den kommunistischen blog
ausgerichtet waren und viele ihrer
fabriken nur über veraltete maschinen
verfügten die mit westlichen standards
einfach nicht mithalten konnten und da
sich der kommunistische block in einem
zustand ist völligen zusammenbruchs
befand sank der umsatz dieser
unternehmen einem solchen ausmaß das die
in eine tiefe krise stürzen in der die
vorstellung jemals wieder profitabel zu
werden eine fata morgana zu sein schien
[Musik]
daher war eine der lösungen die sie sich
ausgedacht haben einige unternehmen und
kleinere einheiten aufzuteilen um den
zugang von kleinen investoren in den
privatisierungsprozess zu erleichtern
aber das war nicht das einzige was die
treuhandanstalt tat um das land auf die
totale annexion vorzubereiten und bisher
zweieinhalb millionen hektar
landwirtschaftliche flächen wurden
privatisiert vermögen des ministeriums
für staatssicherheit also das stasi
wurden verkauft so die armee eigentum
und vermögen der offiziellen politischen
parteien in jedem fall führte dass trotz
aller probleme dazu dass viele
westdeutsche unternehmen am ende ganz
oder teilweise ostdeutsche unternehmen
aufkauften um dort niederlassungen oder
produktionsstätten zu errichten und so
von den niedrigen lohnkosten im osten zu
profitieren
[Musik]
das war gut in dem sinne dass viele
arbeitsplätze erhalten werden konnten
und die produktion gesichert war auch
wenn dieser ganze prozess für die
bevölkerung sehr schmerzhaft und von
vielen korruptions skandalen begleitet
war was sich jedoch als einer der
größten nachteile für die weitere
zukunft der region mit puppen sollte war
die jeweils wollte spezialisierung auch
produktions- und montage phasen mit
geringerer wertschöpfung als in den west
betrieben natürlich gab es auch hier bei
ausnahmen wie zb die innovationszentren
im silicon saxony aber das gesamtbild
vor allem im vergleich zum westen war
eindeutig die konsequenz viele der
qualifiziertesten arbeiter nämlich die
die forschen erfinden und dadurch höhere
werte schaffen gingen oft in den westen
während die einfachen produktions
abschnitte der wertschöpfungskette in
den osten verlegt wurden und die das
ganz normal zu veranschaulichen selbst
im jahr 2016 zogen noch 400.000 deutsche
aus dem osten in den westen wäre nur
150.000 deutsche aus dem westen in den
osten gehen dieses gefälle hat sich im
laufe der zeit in den einkommen der
deutschen im osten und westen verewigt
und natürlich auch im
bruttoinlandsprodukt der neuen und alten
bundesländer auf jeden fall muss man
auch sagen dass die fortschritte
natürlich bemerkenswert sind wie man zum
beispiel auch im vergleich mit anderen
postkommunistischen ländern sieht denn
es war ja alles andere als trivial und
billig ein derart unter entwickeltes
wirtschaftssysteme an eine industrie und
wirtschaftsmacht wie die alte brd
anzugleichen die zahl der dabei
miteinander verknüpften themen die
angegangen gelöst werden mussten und das
in windeseile war schier endlos
infrastruktur wohlstandsniveau
umweltverschmutzung wiederaufbau des
produktions gefüges umbau der städte und
so weiter und so fort die frage die sich
hierbei also stellt ist wie viel hat
dieser ganze prozess wirklich gekostet
wirst du die antwort müssen dann passt
mal auf
[Musik]
der preis der erteilung
machen kann ist die deutsche
wiedervereinigung war und bleibt ein
sehr sehr teures experiment als ich fest
nach schätzungen des instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung in halle hat die
ehemalige kapitalistische brd allein
zwischen 190 und 2009 mehr als 1,3
millionen euro ja billionen also 1300
milliarden ausgegeben um die
wirtschaftliche und soziale angleichung
der ehemaligen ddr zu subventionieren um
die eine vorstellung zu geben das ist
was das doppelte des gesamten
rettungsfonds den die europäische
kommission zur bewältigung der korona
währungskrise genehmigt hat und das ist
noch nicht das ende der fahnenstange
es wird geschätzt dass noch immer jedes
jahr milliarden aus dem westen in den
osten fließen und wofür wurde all dieses
geld ausgegeben und die wurden all diese
ausgaben finanziert nun an dieser stelle
schluss und der auf eine weitere
kontroverse geschichte der nie von
diesem geld wurde für ganz andere zwecke
ausgegeben als ursprünglich vorgesehen
etwas das die menschen im westen nicht
sehr lustig fanden denn obwohl die
ursprüngliche investition darauf
abzielte die wettbewerbsfähigkeit des
ostens zu verbessern also hilfe zur
selbsthilfe zum beispiel durch die
förderung der modernisierung von
unternehmen wurde errechnet seien sehr
großer talent mittels wird ganz andere
zwecke verwendet wurde zum beispiel für
sozialleistungen renten subventionen und
beihilfen aller art
[Musik]
kurz gesagt die politiker haben mit dem
geld ihrer steuerzahler die gelder in
austin bestochen um für sich
wählerstimmen zu kaufen ohne damit in
der praxis irgendwelche produktiven
struktur zu schaffen die dazu dienen
würden nachhaltigkeit eigenständigkeit
autonomie perspektiven und
lebensbedingungen für die zukunft zu
schaffen der und ganz viel von diesem
geld wandert in konsumausgaben und da
der konsumenten markt schon kurz nach
der wende von west konzernen dominiert
wurde floss auch dieses geld umgehend
zurück in deren kassen
[Musik]
ein großer teil des aufbau ost war also
auch ein subventionsprogramm für jene
west ferien die den osten unter sich
aufgeteilt haben viele ostdeutsche
sprechen daher von einer art
kolonisierung wäre sich die
westdeutschen beschweren dass sie ihre
landsleute im osten von ihren almosen
abhängig wurden und auf kosten der
unternehmen und steuerzahlern westen in
saus und braus leben nach berechnungen
der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
wurde das durchschnittseinkommen der
deutschen ohne den solidaritätszuschlag
um rund 900 euro pro jahr höher liegen
es wurden sogar sanktionen für jene
neuen bundesländer gefordert die das
geld nicht zweckgebunden ausgaben dies
wurde jedoch nie durchgesetzt
unter punkt dabei ist beide haben gute
gründe wütend zu sein das problem ist
jedoch dass politik und medien diese wut
von den tatsächlich für diese situation
verantwortlich nämlich den politikern
geschickt um lenken und das zu
instrumentalisieren die beiden
landesteile immer weiter gegeneinander
zu polarisieren teile und herrsche so
funktioniert deutschland heute und so
sehen ostdeutsche die westlich oft noch
als arrogant überheblich rücksichtslos
und bevormunden
und die westdeutsche die sich eigentlich
für maximal tolerant und weltoffen
halten blicken auf ihre ostdeutschen
landsleute oft von einem eingebildeten
moralischen podest herab halten sie für
minderbemittelt unterschiedliche
auffassungen über politik und werte
werden so nicht in einem fairen
demokratischen wettbewerb ausgetragen
und miteinander in einklang gebracht
sondern immer häufiger per
totschlagargument und genereller
delegitimierung systematisch
diskriminiert da hast du es also die
deutsche wiedervereinigung hat eine
menge geld gekostet und so einer neuen
inneren spaltung geführt heute scheint
diese unsichtbare mauer die den osten
vom westen trend immer noch sehr präsent
zu sein errichtet wird sie diesmal aber
nicht nur von den politikern im osten
sondern eben auch im westen denn auch
sie haben gelernt dass die vom teilen
viel mehr profitieren als und einigen
der menschen aber wie anfangs erwähnt
handelt es sich hierbei nun eine der
vielen spaltungen die deutschland im
augenblick auseinandertreiben ein
beispiel dass wir auch auf andere themen
und bereiche übertragen können und
deswegen bis die es erst mal du glaubst
du dass die beiden teile deutschlands
eines tages komplett homogen sein werden
wird es den deutschen gelingen zu
erkennen dass sie in einen teufelskreis
der polarisierung gefangen sind werden
sie diesen irgendwann durchbrechen
können was sollte hierzu getan werden
was könnte jeder einzelne dazu beitragen
teilt eure meinung wird dann immer mit
uns und auch allen anderen ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt uns bitte gleich teilt es mit
freunden und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren macht gut und bis
bald
[Musik]